il a préparé j'ai vu ça sur un stade il
a préparé le petit déjeuner pour sa
femme avec des canards laqués pasa pôle
a pour la femme de feu d'avoir une meuf
[Musique]
tu voudrais que soit on vaccine c'est
pas ça x 100 m lemaitre une aventure
avec un ou une députée dans un avion non
ça c'est dit
oui je pense aussi comme benjamin
pourquoi on sait que les benjamins c'est
moi j'avais sur l'aventuré alors vous
aimez moi de vous dire ça mais je vous
aime beaucoup me line quoi mais question
est ce que j'ai une question à vous
poser qu'on se pose un petit peu ce que
vous n'êtes pas un peu mytho parce que
non mais on m'accepte c'est la vérité
donc quand à utah a couché avec une
passion nous dire de qui il s'agit dans
un ado non non non
castany sinon sera que certaines fois on
sait on comment ça vous sert nenê c'est
bon parce que lui ça va dit mcdowell
non mais attendez top arrêter l'émission
bastien problème non mais je vais
m'occuper de lui pendant la pub j'ai
encore lu m une thalasso et cadettes
vous les gars ont la gueule est austère
alors prenez moi on va apprendre à nos
téléspectateurs
voilà temps si sa jambe mais attention
majeure parce que d'accord alors
généralement temps là quant à moi ce que
dit heureux de la roja mais jamais trop
près d'accord mais qui fait qu est
atteinte est mort là moi je reste à 10
ans après que martin derrière les moyens
voilà je tape et je tape au genou droit
mais non mais je peux pas très bien
vas-y bouge
j'en ai bavé aucun respect non c'est
très beau ce que j'attaque mais moi il
fait beau alors qu'il est nul
ateras sénat porte de base si l'on tape
pour femmes
donc moi j'ai failli me péter le bras
isabelle a dû prendre depuis sept ans je
pense entre 7 à 8 tonnes de fautes sur
le sur le match sur la tronche cjb jeu
télé j'y vis j'y viens gillet a fini à
60 mètres il me semble samedi de
vendredi soir donc ma question est la
suivante est ce que vous ne manquez pas
de couilles alors franchement je suis
jamais le dernier pour faire les trucs
là que 500 est ce que c'est vraiment une
question c'est juste une attaque c'est
entre les belges écrit la chanson en
vous est demandé de 40 mètres depuis que
je suis depuis que dans la poule n'est
pas prêt j'ai côtoyé non mais parce que
j'ai tout fait vous avez dit y suit ce
très bon début la cascade quand j'étais
sur le toit de la voiture les faits vous
j'en ai fait plus que ça c'est ça vous
médias toujours fait plus que ça
le seul truc que vous avez fait plus que
les autres il vous marier
[Applaudissements]